What is that stuff? When you get barbecue
chips, what is, what does Barbara,
first of all,
it does not taste like barbecue.
It has a taste and that taste
is barbecue potato chip tastes.
It's not barbecue oranges,
whatever the flavor is great flavor.
It doesn't taste like grapes at
all. I got out of the bubble girl.
But if somebody gives you a basic gray
bubble gum, be like, oh this is great.
Like it sits as a dealer grape. Yeah. Not
at all true. Yeah, that's true. So true.
Orange soda yet bitch, that is
not orange. Like what is that?
This is not the taste of orange and all
this is the taste like orange. Yeah.
I uh, that's, I hear, I have a, I
do food. It's so fucking bad, dude.
What is barbecue potato chips?
What the fuck is that taste?
Cause that's a weird taste, right?
That does not taste like barbecue.
I tell you this much. It does not
grow in the earth. Whatever it is.
It's some long words and some
scientific sounding shit.
Methyl Alanine Mile Fisk. If pain
should not be putting into your body,
oh, this gotta be trans fats in
them bitches to, oh, come on Joe,
2019 you say that. Still utilize
the transmission's still out.
Outstate trans fats. It's getting there
though. You could say Trans Trans is okay.
You don't,
don't deviate with new sounds with your
face and me and the exact same thing.
Or people get furious. Trans fats are
okay. Trans Femme, he'll get mad at you.
You say it too much.
Like do you just get off on saying trends?
It says when you should trans fats.
I'm a lot of talk.